hi everyone
i'm karen woodall i'm a forensic
toxicologist
um i'm an assistant professor at the
university of toronto the mississauga
campus
in the forensic science programme um and
before i joined there a couple of years
ago
i worked for 20 years at the center of
forensic sciences
in toronto and again as a forensic
toxicologist there
so today uh my presentation is going to
be about the opioid crisis
and the challenges that's created and is
still
happening for forensic toxicology
so i'm going to start just with a brief
uh
history and overview about opioids
so opioids are a group of drugs that
bind to opioid receptors in the body
they first came from natural
plants the opium poppy and
in the 1800s morphine was first
extracted from the opium poppy
and in fact it was a major milestone in
pharmacology
and it was the first time an active
ingredient of a medicinal plant
was isolated morphine itself is named
after the roman god of dreams
morpheus and that's due to the some of
the sedating properties
of opioid drugs
so oh periods as i'm sure you're all
aware um they're
used therapeutically uh to relieve pain
so they can be very good analgesic drugs
but as we also know that this can be
some
uh serious issues with opioid use
and that is mainly due to the high
potential for abuse
so some people that take opioids can um
get a strong euphoric effect so
it leads to uh abuse and unfortunately
overdoses and deaths
another important point about opioids is
that chronic use of opioids can lead to
tolerance
which means you can take more of a drug
without suffering from some of the
effects of the drug
in terms of toxicology this can be
important
because if you're tolerant to opioids it
means you can take
more of an opioid drug before suffering
from some of the adverse effects
there's a few different types of opioids
so
one type is the naturally occurring
opioids
so these are the ones that come from the
opium poppy
some examples of those are morphine
and codeine another type of opioids are
called semi-synthetic opioids
and they have a structure that is
related to
the naturally occurring opioids but
they're altered slightly
and a few examples of those would be
hydromorphone
and oxycodone another group
of opioid drugs are known as synthetic
opioids
and the chemical structure of synthetic
opioids
is not similar at all to the naturally
occurring opioids
yet they still act on opioid receptors
in the body so chemically they're very
diverse group of
drugs but they have the same effects um
on the opioid receptors
so in terms of opioids um how strong are
they
and this is something that's important
for people taking opioids
people prescribing opioids and
different opioids will have different
strengths an example would be
codeine which tends it's a mild opioid
drug
and that might be prescribed for more
minor issues
such as if you have minor dental work
you might get a prescription for codeine
fentanyl on the other hand is an
extremely powerful
opioid and it's only going to be
prescribed
for people with chronic pain conditions
in patients
already tolerant to opioids
you can get charts showing potency of
opioids
and they're used by medical personnel
when they're prescribing
to avoid potentially fatal dosing errors
this is an example of the type of chart
that could be used
so the opioids that other opioids are
compared
to is morphine so morphine has a value
of one
in terms of potency or strength uh so
codeine as i mentioned which
is um kind of a mild opioid that
has one tenth as as strong as morphine
um oxycodone is just a little bit
stronger than morphine
um heroin is five times stronger than
morphine
and then fentanyl is 100 times stronger
than morphine
so you can see just based on this
potency chart
that fentanyl is an extremely strong
opioid drug
and that becomes important when we talk
about the opioid crisis
which brings me to well what is the
opioid crisis
the opioid crisis has been described as
a major health concern and issue
um in north america and it's also
affected many other countries
around the world in north america three
waves have been identified
and so the first wave began in the 1990s
and it was related to the increase in
prescription opioid use
the second wave was related to a slight
shift away from prescription opioid use
to an increase in the use of illicit
heroin
so that was in the early 2000s
and then from about 2013
uh the third wave which has led to
a dramatic increase in the number of uh
opioid deaths
is mainly due to synthetic opioids so
fentanyl is the the main one in this
category
um but there's other newer drugs uh some
are fentanyl analogues that are also uh
detected in this third wave
so why is the uh opioid crisis such a
problem
um well it's a public health concern as
i mentioned
it's uh there's been a dramatic increase
in the number of hospitalizations and
the number of deaths
due to opioid use
and then for toxicology laboratories
laboratories and toxicologists um it's
created an
issue in terms of resources because it's
uh increased the number of uh casework
the number of
samples that need to be tested for the
presence of opioids
and then in the third wave and an
increase in some newer opioids
um there's a lack of information about
some of the types of opioids that are
being used
and that creates issues too
so just talking about some of the public
health
issues this is data from
ontario public health and they have an
online opioid tracker so ontario is
a province in canada um and this shows
the number of opioids present
at death um this graph goes from 2003 to
2019
and if you look at the graph you can see
uh the blue line which
is uh fentanyl or fentanyl-related drugs
in the early 2000s there were probably
less than
five fentanyl-related deaths each year
um
but this graph from around 2014
we started to see a significant
significant
increase in the number of
fentanyl-related deaths
and you could see the last few years so
2017 and on like a really
huge number of fentanyl-related deaths
in the province of ontario
so it goes from being less than
approximately five deaths a year in the
early 2000s
uh to now well over a thousand deaths
per year
the latest uh this data available is
2019
but other information has shown that
this
increase is still continuing uh to this
day
it's a similar trend in the us
in fact in the u.s since the first wave
of the opioid crisis hit
there's been over 500 000 opioid-related
deaths
so you could see why it's considered
such a significant public health concern
in 2019 data from the cdc
uh shows that around 73 percent of all
opioid-related deaths
were due to synthetic opioids and these
were mainly
uh fentanyl and fentanyl-related drugs
and in that year 2019 there were over 36
000 deaths
involving those types of drugs in the
united states
interestingly too the source of fentanyl
is more likely to be
illicitly manufactured rather than
pharmaceutical
fentanyl and that was one of the big
shifts that occurred with the third wave
of the opioid crisis it's this illicitly
manufactured fentanyl
and other newer opioid drugs
uh recently with the current copit19
pandemic
the opioid crisis is still a significant
concern and in fact
the number of opioid-related deaths in
north america
um has increased since the pandemic
this study was published in november
again from the province of ontario
and it was looking at patterns
surrounding opioid-related deaths
during the pandemic um the preliminary
data showed that during the first 15
weeks of the pandemic
there was a 38 increase in opioid
related deaths
compared to the time period just before
the province went into
um like social distancing measures
um and lockdown provisions
some trends that was no that were
noticed in this study
were that uh a lot of individuals were
using drugs alone
a lot of deaths were occurring outdoors
um in hotels and motels
and it was um thought that
there's a possibility that the increase
in death
is due to what partly due to uh reduced
access
to um assistance during the pandemic
um and that could contribute because uh
people have less access to treatment
uh reduced support networks if they're
socially isolated and taking drugs alone
um and they suffer an overdose
somebody might not be available to give
them naloxone for example
um so the opioid crisis
is still continuing and the current code
19 pandemic appears to have
made things worse
so uh because fentanyl has uh created
such an
issue of uh this opioid crisis i'm just
gonna
briefly give an overview about fentanyl
um
so i mentioned uh earlier in the
presentation that fentanyl
is a synthetic opioid um so it's fast
acting
it's used a lot in hospitals so it can
be used clinically to pre-medicate prior
to surgery
it's available by a prescription
in the form of pain patches so you can
wear it on your skin
for up to three days and get constant
pain relief
um if you're giving it in hospital then
it tends to be
in an injectable liquid form
illicit fentanyl is often
sold in the form of a powder and some of
the
issues that you can get with illicit
fentanyl is that
people don't always know that it's
fentanyl that they're getting
so sometimes they might buy something
and they think it's heroin
sometimes they might buy something that
they think it's it's cocaine
and because fentanyl is such a powerful
opioid uh they don't have the tolerance
to fentanyl
so it can cause accidental overdoses
because
people are not aware of what they're
getting
um in addition to fentanyl there's a
number of fentanyl analogues
uh fentanyl analogues are chemically
related to fentanyl
but they are slightly modified
and then another issue in the opioid
crisis is
counterfeit pharmaceuticals these are
tablets that are made to look like
a proper pharmaceutical tablet however
they contain
um illicitly manufactured drugs um
the picture on this slide um is a
picture of
um a counterfeit oxycontin tablets
so they're green oxycontin 80 tablets
but they actually contain fentanyl and
again
if people are buying what they think is
oxycodone
but it has fentanyl they end up with a
much stronger opioid
and there's been a lot of overdose
deaths associated with people consuming
these
fake pharmaceutical products
the novel psychoactive substances are a
group
of drugs that legally mimic the effects
of
traditional drugs of abuse so for
example hallucinogens
stimulants cannabinoids or opioids
and they're not internationally
controlled so they're designed
so um people can buy these
substances and um they're legally able
to do it
and in the field of forensic toxicology
there's been
um like a proliferation of these novel
psychoactive
substances and it creates a lot of
challenges
for forensic toxicologists
so some of the challenges for example
forensic toxicologists are going to be
some of the frontline people to help
identify
some of these emerging nps trends
it's really important for toxicology
labs to be able to collaborate with law
enforcement
coroners medical examiners and public
health officials
and some of the things that forensic
toxicologists have to do
is to have the ability to identify these
drugs
hopefully to be able to quantify the
drugs
and then help interpret the drug
findings because if they're a new
compound
not only do you have to be able to
identify it but you've got to be able to
tell people well
is this a significant amount is it a
toxic amount
is it even a potentially fatal amount
and that can be hard to do
in terms of kind of being on the front
line and helping public health
for example if it's a novel psychoactive
substance that's a new opioid
if a lab is able to add a new opioid to
an analytical method it's going to help
provide
important surveillance information for
public health agencies
sometimes timely data collection in an
outbreak can have a significant
impact in supporting public policy or
allowing points of intervention to be
identified
and sometimes with some of these opioid
drugs
you might get an outbreak so for example
in one particular location there's a bad
batch of drugs that contains
a very strong opioid or a new opioid
that nobody's seen before
and if a forensic lab can help identify
the drugs
and alert public health they can uh give
out
warnings to people in the drug community
um and they could at least be aware that
there's an issue with
some of the supply of drugs um a lot of
areas
they have naloxone kits available um
but if people know that there's an issue
with the drug supply
it might encourage them to have these
uh additional kind of intervention ready
to go
if there's issues
so with the um appearance of
the some of these novel psychoactive
substances
um and in particular the opioids in
terms of the opioid crisis
some of the challenges are that
compounds can appear and disappear
very rapidly so a new drug might appear
one month
and then two or three months later it
might be gone from the market
so laboratories need to be able to adapt
quickly
for many uh forensic toxicology
laboratories
with limited resources this can be a
real issue
so some um forensic labs they're
publicly funded
they're able to do kind of routine
testing and they can do it quite well
but if you get new drugs that need to be
tested
you might have to decide well where are
we going to put our resources
which drugs are going to be more
prevalent
and also which drugs are going to be
more toxic
could should we focus on those first
an example of that would be the uh the
first appearance of car fentanyl so
in canada it first appeared on the drug
scene
in around 2016 and that was similar to
the united states now car fentanyl
is a um related to fentanyl so it's a
fentanyl analog
it's approved for use in large animals
but it has no approved use in humans
and in terms of potency carfentanil
is a hundred times stronger than
fentanyl
and it's ten thousand times stronger
than morphine
so you could see just looking at the
strength of carfentanil
how it could be a real issue if people
are
starting to take drugs that contain
carfentanil
so for forensic labs it created
analytical challenges
because carfentanil appears in in the
drug supply
and a lab needs to be able to adapt to
that and be able to
test biological samples to see if
carfentanil is present
and if so how much is present so
you need to be able to establish a
sensitive method
so you can quantitate carfentanil and
when it's a drug such as carfentanil
that is so
potent you need to have a method that's
capable of detecting very very low
concentrations
and that can be a challenge and it can
take time to set up a method so you can
see that also even just something as
simple as obtaining analytical standards
for method development can be difficult
there's a lot of restrictions on being
able to get
car fentanyl standards that you need to
develop a method
so sometimes it can take months just to
get the
the legal ability to buy car fentanyl
standards for the laboratory to be able
to
develop these methods and when it takes
months to develop these methods
that people are still kind of dying of
overdoses
that creates a real challenge for a
toxicology lab
because you want to be able to keep up
to date and be able to assist
investigators in what drugs are
currently being used
another example of this is the
uh novel psychoactive opioid
u47700
now similar to car fentanyl this first
appeared in canada
and again similar in the united states
in around 2016.
um this drug the users of this drug
report that
it's more euphoric than fentanyl so some
of the drug using communities
they like this drug it was going to be a
popular drug
even though we call it a novel
psychoactive substance
it was actually first developed in 1978
by a pharmaceutical company
but it never actually progressed and was
used in humans so it first appeared so
in canada for example i think it was
approximately five deaths were first
reported in 2016
early 2017 and then there was a change
in the legal status and it became a
scheduled
one-control substance and this change in
the legal status
meant that the popularity of u477
uh zero zero like just immediately
uh dropped and actually
users then switched to a similar drug
zero u49900 um it's an analog
four seven seven zero zero so it's
um it's structurally uh similar
but this wasn't uh made by a pharmacy
pharmaceutical company
so there was absolutely no published
literature about this drug
so it was a brand new chemical so
toxicology labs had to develop
methods for the detection of this drug
there's no information available
about toxic concentrations potentially
fatal concentrations
and it's an example of how things change
very very quickly
just because of a scheduling change so
in canada and in the united states when
both
the government set legal restrictions on
you four seven seven
zero zero the drug community immediately
switched to another chemical
so it's that plain catch-up that
forensic toxicology labs
uh have to do
so how do forensic toxicology labs can
monitor these drug trends that are going
on
because you can get trends in countries
but even within countries in different
regional areas one drug might be popular
for a few
months and then change and then in a
different
area a different drug might become
popular so again
it's that adapt like forensic labs have
to adapt to
all these changes so it's very important
for labs to try to
to monitor what's going on so how does
forensic toxicologist do that
well drug seizures can be a great source
of information
so um sometimes drugs are seized
at the border they can get tested police
investigations maybe if they seize drugs
in a drug trafficking investigation
if that drug is tested the information
from those drug seizures provides
information about what's currently out
on the streets
another way is testing in forensic
laboratories or testing in clinical
laboratories
sometimes if labs identify a new drug
they will publish the method they'll
alert the community and say
hey this is this is a new compound that
we've just found in this
area um a good way of keeping up to date
with information
is the society of forensic toxicologists
so their website has information on a
lot of the new
novel psychoactive opioids and other
drugs too
published case reports can be a good way
of getting information
although by the time a case report is
published it can be
you know at least two or three months
out a day and because the drug trends
change so quickly
um it might already be out of date but
it's still good to know
kind of what's out there so for example
a published case report might be
a couple of deaths that have occurred
due to some
novel opioid that's appeared
and then an additional source of
information is actually some of the
websites that drug users use
so they will post information about
drugs what they're currently using what
the effects are
they'll compare like the strength of the
drugs to like other drugs that are
already on the market some examples of
that would be error word
reddit or a website called psychonaut
wiki
so forensic toxicologists sometimes find
it useful to monitor some of these drug
user websites
because it does provide some good
information
some other useful resources that are
really good
is in the united states the drug
enforcement administration
and the national forensic laboratory
information system
they both provide information on
drugs that are detected in drug testing
labs and forensic laboratories
all across the united states and that
information is available on their
website
so it's a great way of keeping up to
date with what drugs
are currently being seen
and then in europe they have a european
monitoring center for drugs
and drug addiction and they have a
really good
early warning system on new psychoactive
substances
so they'll provide information about
what drugs that are currently being
seen in europe and what some of the
effects of the drugs are
like if there's any deaths being
reported so again
it provides a lot of useful information
and it's really important for forensic
toxicologists to try and keep up to date
with some of the changes that are
occurring
um because there's so many challenges
with being able to
keep up with what's being used out in
the
out in the real world
okay so thank you for listening um i
provided the overview about challenges
for forensic toxicologists in relation
to the opioid crisis
um and if you have any follow-up
questions please feel free to email me
my email address is karen.woodall at
utoronto.ca
so thanks very much